[Music]
blue ivy carter just showed off her
dance moves and
yep she got it from her mama this makes
me proud
queen bee's mama and blue's grandma tina
knowles lawson hit up instagram on
sunday
to share the cutest clip of the
nine-year-olds at her dance class
like you just have to see it
[Music]
um she is literally a better dancer than
well all of us
jay-z and bee's little girl freaking
hits the beat like a boss
rocking out to ciara's gimme dat but
frankly
i relate more to this little cutie in
the background
hopping is my signature move
[Music]
oh man i'm winded anyway
while blue is giving us major beyonce
vibes
her grandma says in this clip blue is
actually more like her aunt
beyonce's little sis solange
not bad at all she captioned the clip
quote
this is blue but i swear it looks like
solange dancing at this age
[Music]
i just want to thank blue ivy on behalf
of
literally everyone for swooping in and
blessing our feed with this cuteness
i'm very happy but this isn't the first
time blue has crushed life and made us
all feel like underachievers
is this the biggest thing you've ever
done becoming a mom this is my greatest
greatest accomplishment and i am the
happiest
i've ever been and i feel the most
empowered
i don't care if i won awards or
you know i don't care if i made good
money whatever
this makes me feel strong and this makes
me
feel so lucky to be a woman in 2020 she
was featured in her famous mama's visual
album
blackest king a lot
[Music]
she even sang on the track brown skin
girl
proving that the apple didn't fall far
from the tree
[Music]
yeah that collab earned blue her first
grammy nom and
won her the bet her award in june making
her the show's
youngest award winner ever and get this
blues talent expands beyond music too
she's quite a makeup artist
tina shared this selfie on instagram in
october
rocking skeleton makeup courtesy of blue
i bought blue so many makeup kits uh
much to her her dad's dismay but um
yeah because you know dads don't like
that but uh it's just for playtime
okay we have fun she's amazing what is
like her specialty
eyes oh my gosh she puts stones and does
all this fancy stuff she can do a
perfect cat eye and in november little
miss
booked and busy added narrator to her
resume
and when my hair is in two puffs i'm
above the clouds
like a superhero my hair
even does magic tricks yeah that's blue
lending her voice to the children's book
hair love by matthew a cherry
one day rocky and i were playing outside
when along came the rain from large
small it went presto just like that
there's nothing my hair can't do so
safe to say this little nine year old is
just killing the game
all around for blue to be a part of it
it's amazing
you